[Music]
over the past decade we have seen many
instances of black americans being
subjected to
police violence with video capturing
what unfolded but before that the 1991
rodney king meeting was the first time
most americans saw this type of violence
from officers
to remind you of what happened we're
going to show you the video
we do want to warn you it's violent you
can see in this video los angeles police
officers kicking and beating king after
a car chase that beating and what
followed is the focus of the first
episode
of boiling point it's a new docu-series
from b-e-t a division
of viacom cbs and it looks at issues
confronting black americans
through a critical social justice
through critical social justice moments
in our history here's the reaction after
the officers were acquitted
nearly 29 years ago
i don't believe this racist ass country
people are sick
this was a modern day
i see what i see how are you going to
justify this
that's when i saw what america was about
that's when i saw
who we were you know they told us loud
and clear my little boy
he wanted to be a cop just like his
father but after seeing that tape he
doesn't want to be that anymore
he's two years old how do i raise him
not to
be prejudiced how do i do that
when there's no justice for him because
he's born black
hassan kwame jefferies who is featured
in the series joins us now he is an
associate professor of history at the
ohio state university
professor good morning to you so in 1991
a
neighbor here's a commotion outside
happens to have just bought a camcorder
and he captures on
film the rodney king beating how does
the conversation about race in this
country
change because of that footage
well the footage is critical it's
shocking and it shocks many americans
but it's important to point out too that
it didn't necessarily it was even
shocking african-americans
but it wasn't necessarily surprising
african-americans had knew
and understood and have been dealing
with police violence and police
brutality as long as they have been
police
but to see it captured in video in such
stark terms
uh as as video and hand held cameras and
the personal cameras were becoming more
common
really uh shook uh the nation
but what was equally important as that
moment
was what happens a year later with the
trial and acquittal of the officers
which then raised questions about what
could actually happen even in the face
of such stark evidence so when we think
about the progress from then to now
the cameras are more ubiquitous the
technology's gotten better there's a lot
more of this kind of video but have you
seen progress
on the uh the the policing side and also
the
accountability side
well certainly there has been change but
the degree of
progress is really relative particularly
as it relates to accountability
one thing that we know is that over the
last since over the last 29 years just
as you pointed out
more and more cameras have been
available more and more of these
incidents have been captured on film but
at the same time
the number of cases has not declined so
it really raises the question
just capturing these moments on film is
that enough
certainly to raise the consciousness of
people but is that enough to bring
justice
and sadly the answer to that
unfortunately is no
that's what i wanted to know professor
jeffreys just earlier in this in this
very broadcast we had a story from san
clemente california
black man crossing the street jaywalking
has an encounter with the police it ends
up deadly
and you can just see as it escalates and
i think we go back to the george floyd
case
uh just just last year what do you think
it's going to take to bring to re
what do you think it'll take to bring
real change and what does the
involvement the participation of white
people in this conversation how much of
a difference does that make
well gail i think what really is going
to
lead to change is actually holding
officers who
violate the constitutional rights of
anybody accountable
those who use deadly force when clearly
it is unnecessary
until we get to the moment where we hold
them not just police departments civilly
responsible but actually hold
officers who commit these crimes
criminally responsible
then we won't see a change in behavior
we've poured millions of dollars
into anti-bias training for police
officers into adding cameras
and we see over the last seven or eight
years that has not
uh significantly changed the behavior
so we need to have uh criminal justice
accountability
and it is critically important that
everyone all americans all concerned
people get behind this movement
and which is why one of the great things
from last summer the summer of 2020
was to see the black lives matter
protest protesting for
justice criminal justice reform justice
for the individuals of police violence
brought out so many people not just
black folk but black people white people
latinos
asians it was a multi-racial
multi-ethnic
movement of millions demanding justice
that's what we need
professor jeffries this series the
donkey series boiling points there are
several moments that come to mind
there's katrina there's bloody sunday
there's the rodney king beating
when you think of themes or lessons that
emerge what are they
well there are these boiling points
there are these moments of crisis
moments where things come to a head and
we don't know how they're going to turn
out uh things could become better
in these moments of crisis or things can
become worse
it all depends on how people react
african americans have always been
pushing the envelope and demanding
justice in these moments of crisis
how does the state react how does
government react how do white citizens
react
and and what's the basis for that
reaction sometimes
such as in the case of the rodney king
beating when it came to
holding those officers accountable white
citizens white jurors
did not hold them accountable they
failed their civic obligation
and that led to the uprising that was a
response
responding to the moment but also a much
longer history so all of these moments
we
i think as ordinary people have the
power to decide what comes next
professor jeffrey says anybody told you
you look like congressman jeffries
they said that i look like his better
brother
so i'll leave it at that he may dispute
that thank you
all right professor jeffries thank you
very much we appreciate it boiling point
a six-part docu-series premieres
this sunday on b-e-t you're watching cbs
this morning